tras El veredicto en la corte de
Brooklyn que declaró culpable de delitos
de narcotráfico al ex secretario de
seguridad pública Federal mexicano
Genaro García Luna el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador exhortó a este
exfuncionario a que como testigo
colaborador revele si el expresidente
Felipe Calderón quien era su jefe le dio
las órdenes de pactar con los criminales
dijo también que sería bueno que el
propio ex mandatario panista Felipe
Calderón diga no nada más por qué puso a
García Luna como secretario de seguridad
sino por qué lo mantuvo en el cargo
Durante los seis años de su gobierno y
si nunca anotó nada raro que sugiriera
una relación con la delincuencia
organizada
también López Obrador cuestionó la
resolución de los jueces acá en México
de liberar las cuentas bancarias de la
esposa de García Luna dijo que el
consejo de la judicatura Federal debe
una explicación pues no es posible que
mientras en Estados Unidos se esté
declarando culpable a García Luna acá en
México se liberen las cuentas bancarias
de su esposa López Obrador dedicó buena
parte de su conferencia en Palacio
Nacional a este tema y dijo que los
llamados de los diputados de su partido
de morena y del dirigente de este
partido de retirarle el registro al
partido Acción Nacional Una vez que se
demostró dicen los diputados que este
partido es una agencia de asociación con
criminales López Obrador dijo que es
parte de su libertad de expresión pero
lo que él demanda es que Calderón y en
todo caso Vicente Fox su antecesor
aclaren lo ocurrido con Genaro García
Luna